the jurgen experience so so when you
base your
your core beliefs on things that are not
reality based on things that are are
based on wishful thinking so a lot of
people get into astrology because
they want to believe that you know there
are fates out there that are
going to look after them or whatever
yeah and if you indulge in wishful
thinking that way the evidence now shows
you actually compromise your mind's
immune system so
when you believe things because you want
to you want them to be true
your mental your mind's immune system
gets weaker and there's actually now
empirical research
that indicates this so so if you for
example um
accept that uh
that clinging to your your your articles
of faith
no matter what is a virtue you're less
likely to change your mind
when evidence comes along right and when
that happens you become more susceptible
to conspiracy thinking more more
susceptible to
uh divisive political ideologies
more susceptible to uh science denial
um your resist your mind's resistance to
bad ideas
starts to decay you can actually damage
your mind's immune system
by indulging in wishful thinking
that makes sense do you do you highlight
specific strategies
uh in your book for looking at things
accurately
and looking at things objectively yeah i
mean
so so science is clearly a shining
example
of what's possible uh in the way of idea
testing
and the way of validating things with
evidence so
you know scientists are especially good
at uh
testing things in laboratories or with
experiments
um now philosophers have always gone in
for a kind of a
related but slightly different kind of
idea testing
philosophers don't have laboratories
except the ones between their ears
and basically we test ideas against each
other and we test ideas
with questions and a lot of times and we
test ideas against our
our intuitions about right and wrong and
try to figure out what makes sense
um that's a complementary kind of idea
testing that scientists go in for
and it's one that has done a huge
amount to educate and
enlighten us over the centuries
and so there what i try to do in the
book is
is take things from this cutting edge
science i call cognitive immunology
it's the science of mental immunity you
combine that with ancient wisdom
about how to how to pursue wisdom how to
find wisdom
and you actually get some really
powerful ways to strengthen
mental immune systems in like what ways
what what do you use personally do you
need it or you've
been sort of indoctrinated into the
world of objective thinking to the point
where you don't need any systems that
you follow
well i try i try not to think that i
have all the answers and that i've uh
you know got it all figured out um look
at humility we know this
humility is really important for for a
well-functioning mental immune system
for everything right well yeah yeah sure
let's go let's go with that
my research specializes in
you know trying to understand how the
mind develops resistance
to bad ideas and once you think you have
all the answers you stop learning
and your thinking starts to go haywire
so you got to maintain that humility
or you know you're just
you're compromising your own mind
humility specifically humility's
important fair-mindedness
like so so if so a lot of people do this
they they um
they ridicule or deride other people's
ideas for failing to meet basic
standards but then they don't apply
those same standards to their own views
right like you have an example of this
um sure um
well i think a whole lot of political
uh rhetoric has this character right
slam the other side um
ridicule it as as a sloppy thinking or
as
ideologically driven but never examine
to see whether your own views
that's a perfect example of it right and
politics is probably
the very best example of how people do
this they get
super tribal they only look at exactly
the other side is being bad
their side they find justifications for
every questionable behavior
every weird scandal every you know
everything that doesn't fit the
narrative
yeah and i'd say that politics is
probably the best example
but religion and ethics and sometimes
economics or others so
wherever values come into play people
get very attached to their ideas
we all want to think that that we're
we're right and true and
virtuous so whatever ideas
we've already internalized as beliefs
they have to be the virtuous beliefs
and any new incoming information that
challenges them from the other side of
the political aisle or from another
religion
or from those damn atheists over there
that's the enemy
and then your mind's immune system
attacks that information
and you never become and you never gain
the fair mindedness needed to learn
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience